Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my brand new Marvel
spider-man video you probably saw the
news recently that Sony is considering
doing Disney Plus spider-man series
which is huge
so we'll break it all down there's a
bunch of Easter eggs this also includes
some venom stuff too if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what
kind of spider-man series you want them
to do on Disney Plus so just going down
the list here starting with number 5 all
this information about the spider-man
Disney Plus series starts with the
director of the spider-man venom
spin-off movie silver and black for
those of you that have asked about that
recently they are still making a silver
sable black cat movie the director of
that movie revealed that behind the
scenes Sony and Marvel are close to
doing the movie as a Disney Plus series
they didn't say how many episodes it
would be but it sounds like six episodes
like the other Marvel Disney Plus series
just because of budgetary constraints
the reason why all the Marvel series are
six episodes one division Falcon and
Winter Soldier too, the Loki series is
because they spent about a hundred and
fifty million dollars making them and
they can put more money into each
episode if they make fewer episodes
that's their way of avoiding having to
do filler episodes but this silver and
black Disney Plus project is just one of
the first spider-man Disney Plus
projects because for remember last year
when Sony announced that it had five
different live-action spider-man TV
series in development they got all
mysterious about it around the time that
they and Marvel split briefly around d23
with spider-man being out of the MCU
well that's fantastic a really smart
decision young man's dad it's God poof
that didn't last very long they worked
everything out inside a new sharing deal
I just did a video last week about Tom
Holland talking about spider-man 3
It says here on the box it says some
friendly neighborhood spider gin love
Ryan. If I'm wrong correct me but I
believe you were supposed to start
shooting spider-man in July I'm not too
sure I was I was in Berlin making a film
called uncharted with Mark Wahlberg and
we were all ready to go we went to set
for day one shooting and then we got
shut down and we all got sent home so
whether we shoot that movie first or we
shoot spider-man first
I'm unclear but I don't know. But
both movies are being made and they're
both really strong and the scripts are
fantastic so whatever happens happens
but I'm ready to play both I mean I play
spider-man enough now I could play him
tomorrow so ready to go.
But while the Sony Marvel fight was
still going on last year they were
trying to trump up their prospects
without Marvel saying how they'd be fine
without the MCU they keep making their
Tom Hollands spider-man films in
addition to the venom movies and all the
spin-offs that they have planned for
those big characters and they were like
on top of all that we'd also start a
development of five different
live-action spider-man TV series and
spin-offs we know what a couple of those
shows are so we'll talk about them in a
second but then Marvel and Sony signed a
new sharing deal answered all these big
movie questions that we had about the
future of Tom Hollands spider-man the
future of the venom character and their
crossovers but there was still this big
question about how they were going to
handle all these spider-man TV shows
what network would they be on which
characters would they follow how many
episodes would they be when are they
going to premiere so three because of
all this
spider-man Disney plus series talk
around silver and black it sounds like
Sony and Marvel both want to keep those
spider-man series on Disney Plus
anything that winds up making it through
development now just because they say
they're developing five shows doesn't
mean they're going to make five shows but
even if they can't do all five it's
still a total no-brainer for both Disney
and Sony Disney is desperately in need
of new content for Disney plus they
barely have any new Marvel or Star Wars
shows this year outside of the
mandalorian Falcon and Winter Soldier
and one division so imagine once they do
get these up and running they have one
spider-man series per year it'd be
amazing for Sony too because Marvel
would be paying them a ton of money for
exclusivity in probably covering some of
the production costs
there was talked a while ago from the
Sony executives about the future of the
Sony Marvel sharing deal for the Tom
Hollands spider-man character in their
relationship they said that they
expected that to continue they would
sign new sharing deals meaning that
spider-man for whatever that winds up
being will be a Marvel film but they
might also consider doing co-productions
for some of these spider-man TV series
if they're going to go to Disney Plus to
get Disney to pay for some of the costs
so don't be surprised if when Marvel and
Sony have to resign another sharing deal
these new spider-man TV series have
something to do with that
- like a lot of you have asked why
aren't the spider-man movies on Disney
Plus right now it's only because the
licensing deals Sony made for their
movies a long time ago once those expire
they can put the spider-man movies on
Disney Plus no problem
Marvel even has the same problem with
some of his other MCU movies they don't
even have all the non spider-man MCU
movies on Disney Plus right now but as
only because of deals that they signed a
long time ago that just haven't expired
yet the other really big benefit of
doing spider-man series as Marvel Disney
Plus series is that they typically push
more money into fewer episodes and they
feature all the movie actors playing
their characters now Sony didn't say
anything about Tom Hollands showing up
during silver and black for instance and
we don't have a lot of the other
spider-man live-action characters yet on
the Sony side of things that's a big
problem for them right now
they're still trying to build their
universe out they have some of the venom
characters they have the Morbius movie
coming up with a bunch of new characters
but there are over 900 different
characters that they have the rights to
because of the way the spider-man movie
rights work you also have to consider
that even though we have spider-verse
there's a ton of characters in that
movie only some of those voice actors
would be viable to play the live-action
versions of their characters on other
series or movies Hailee Steinfeld is
probably the best example she does the
voice for spider-gwen in spider-man into
the spider verse she'd actually make a
really great live-action spider-gwen you
remember that she was actually up for
the role of the Kate Bishop Hawkeye on
the Hawkeye Disney Plus series but now
it looks like she might not be playing
that character leaving her free to play
other characters like live-action
spider-gwen so number 2 what are those
spider-man series Sony is developing
well Sony said that they're already
developing spin-offs for some of the
spider-verse characters so probably a
Miles Morales live-action series a
spider-gwen
live-action series for Hailee
Steinfeld's character probably a villain
series of some kind like Marvel is
developing a Thunderbolts Disney Plus
series Sony probably wants to do the
same type of project with a group of
villains kingpin would be amazing now
that would involve some sharing between
Marvel and Sony but it would just be
incentive for them to move a little bit
closer I've done a couple videos about
daredevil possibly showing up during
spider-man 3 the whole thing with the
Netflix Marvel characters is that Marvel
or
initially Sony can do anything that they
want with those characters after
November so a lot of you want to see
kingpin show up in the movies at some
point it's totally possible they could
do something with him on Disney Plus as
part of a big spider-man project those
are just some of the shows I think are
more likely but there are five total so
a couple other ones that could wind up
doing would be an animated spider-verse
TV series with the same actors playing
the characters after they do some of the
sequels and this is just speculation but
I would love to see them try to do a
live-action spider-man 2099 series
either set in the future or with him
time traveling into the past is wishful
thinking it'd be like Warner Brothers
doing a live-action Batman Beyond TV
show they're both amazing characters but
it'd be super expensive it'd be like
doing Blade Runner with spider-man
characters.
Woah! What the?!
I'm spider-man, I need you to come with me. Who the heck are you?
I just told you that listen I'm from the
future how dare you point at me. You were
pointing first. It's rude to point. You're being very rude!
As funny as it would be
to see them do something
like that in live-action that would
probably have to be an animated show but
Oscar Isaac does the voice for
spider-man 2099 he would make an amazing
live-action spider-man 2099 if they can
ever pull off the live-action
spider-verse movie Amy Pascal said that
the studio was considering a live-action
spider-verse project but the way she
talked about it made it sound like they
were thinking about doing it as a movie
before they'd ever do it as a TV series
and even if they are able to pull that
off it wouldn't happen till after
spider-man four and that's not going to
come out till 2023 so we're talking
Avengers five territory that's so far
down the road it's too hard to speculate
at this point in number one when would
these spider-man Disney Plus series
premiere if they do wind up happening
the silver sable black hat project
sounds like it's a little further along
so that'd be the next two years probably
but all the other spider-man spin-off TV
series probably wouldn't be till 2022 or
2023 at the earliest still a long ways
off the virus delayed everything right
now but even without that Marvel and
Sony's first big spider-man priority
right now is the movies spider-man 3
venom 2 in the big spider-man venom
crossover movie I've already done a
couple videos about spider-man 4 we
don't know if that's going to be their
big Sinister Six team-up movie or if
it's just going to be another regular
solo spider-man movie with him in
college for those EES that are wanting
an older version of spider-man he's
slowly getting their Tom Holland is
getting a little bit older with each
movie but let me know in the comments if
they wind up doing Marvel Disney Plus
spider-man series which characters do
you want those series to be about I'm
still working on my next infinity saga
re-watch in Easter eggs video that's
going to be for the Thor movie that should
post in the next couple of days as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see that video when I
post it every one click here for that
Tom Hollands spider-man 3 clip and click
here for that brand new Avengers
infinity saga scene of Doctor Strange
becoming Iron Man and Iron Man becoming
Doctor Strange thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight!